what'd y'all think of that oscars deal
man
i thought it was like a like tim said it
was a nice shot wasn't loaded up it was
like you couldn't see it coming it was
boom it was direct open hand so he
didn't drop him which was you know best
case scenario because i don't think he
wanted to knock him out right you know
what i mean so a good slap
i thought it was a good shot
do you think rock handled it as well as
he could like because rocky
it's at a certain point it looks like he
thinks that it's gonna be he's joking
yeah
and then i'm sure at a certain point i
bet it was very close quarters when the
energy probably changed in his mind he's
like oh this is not a joke what do i do
do you think rock did the best thing
that he could have done oh [ __ ] yeah
dude
i think so i mean you see him kind of
want to get fired up but i think he did
it the best because what the [ __ ] is he
supposed to do and imagine what would
have happened if will smacked him and it
piled up chris oh just boarded him yeah
that would have been bad that's what i'm
saying good thing it wasn't a it wasn't
like a boom that's the same scenario of
colby jorge i was thinking i'm like that
was my best case scenario that that
jorge didn't knock colby out hit his
head kill him so you ran into chris at
the after party
yeah bro so it was pretty wild so spade
took me over to the um
who actually is from arizona shout out i
think he's from scottsdale hey uh
so spade invited me to be his his uh
guest or whatever we went to the um
vanity fair party
and then we went to some other dude a
rich guy's house this dude was really
really rich like they had a machine in
the front you could just get money out
of it it was just like it was a 8 p.m
but you could guess any number and it
gave you it was like this dude was real
real rich like yeah they had even his
dog had like a little wallet on the side
dude
so this dude was really really rich and
we went in and like
jennifer lawrence is sitting in the back
just hanging out outside like just in
her pajamas she like lived next door i
guess and so she came over because she
heard some commotion or whatever
so she's out back just hanging out like
there's like pelling out the
pellanepi cruise
uh
like a you know just fancy people i mean
it's like fancy people you see on the
magazine and they're just sitting there
you know eating you know they had some
raviolis
um what else did they have they had a
salad that looked
it was a little i thought a little bit
of wilted but people were eating it
rich people will eat
they'll eat kind of more they'll say
it's like uh more artistic kind of but
anyway so
we get to finally see chris rock right
and so and i'm with david spade so spade
knows him so
they're just kind of talking and he was
just shocked he was like what the [ __ ]
happened he's almost it reminded me of
you ever been at a party and somebody
gets hit by somebody
and then the person that hit him leaves
and there was never really like a big
fight or maybe there even was a fight
but the one dude never had any idea
there was any beef or anything going on
and then you start talking to that guy
and he's like bro what the [ __ ] happened
like what what do you think you know
that's kind of what it was he was just
like what the [ __ ] so did he not know
that she had alopecia or whatever
disease that's why she was bald did he
not know that i think he had no clue i
think he had no clue and who don't have
alopecia everybody's going bald yeah
well it's
i'm not
but not yet exactly and when you start
dude it's going to look crazy like one
of those things that kids used to put on
the end of their pencils that's how it
is going to be watching this is the
front or the back
oh yeah which what do you want to lose
first you think if you had to lose your
back i just shaved the back so i was
having a good front profile talking to
chicks yeah you got to go at the front
yeah then you turn around no i wouldn't
turn around it's a salvage yard back
there yeah
did you notice any of those a-listers
judging you
you know this party there was no uh
and i've never been i've been to some
fancy spaces but i've never been
anything like this like apparently this
is like the party to end up at right
were you wearing a suit
yeah oh good i was wearing a suit
and um
yes so we were sitting that space we
watched the oscars over there so we're
just watching and then that the uh the
slap happens and it went mute on the
television everybody's like damn
and we didn't know if it was real and
then all these text messages started
coming in
um
and then we ended up oh we went to the
vanity fair and nobody was really kind
of talking about it i think everybody
was kind of in shock or the
contemplating of those real or not right
that's what i was wondering yeah yeah
there was a guy there was a guy uh a
writer there and i remember him saying i
don't think that it was real
and i'm like i don't think the acting
could be that great that way bro um
and so yeah then we ended up at the
party and then rock was there which i
thought was the cool movie's at the
party he's not like ducking anything you
know i think he thought it was really
weird he didn't look like affected he
didn't have like a little cast on his
jaw or nothing
you know um what would you have done if
you got smacked like that i don't think
you i think your reactions
so fast i think you wouldn't have been
able to be hit by that but what yeah
what do you think i think i would have
been i think at a i at a certain point
as he's approaching i think i would have
squared up yeah i would have at least
embraced like taking on the idea that
something was gonna happen yeah put up
karate hands i already done something
peaceful karate hands even these yeah
just just some separation though between
yeah
yeah i'd have done something or at least
position myself like it was something
was gonna happen i still might get hit
but some you know i'm gonna look like
i'm ready to get hit
but rock took it like a like a champ bro
i agree he took it like a champ um
what rematch would you rather see
mosby doll
versus colby or rock versus smith
rockford smith probably just because i
don't know how that plays out but colby
vs jorge
i think i mean
i think that plays out pretty similar to
how it played out the first time yeah i
agree well how much bigger is will than
chris
i think at least 50 pounds i know that
how tall is chris you mind checking that
out
how tall is chris rock
510
wow i wonder if either can scrap will
smith is six one and a
half did you measure about the oscars uh
he looked it up oh oh he did and then i
got bored of looking it up because i was
trying to figure out the weights or
whatever and i just went to sleep yeah i
did that sometimes but uh
yeah so that's a good scrap though
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one